un grand prix de saint-marin chargée
d'émotion puisqu'il marquait le 10e
anniversaire de la mort sur cette même
piste d'ayrton senna
plusieurs hommages ont été rendus au
pilote brésilien qui était un surdoué de
l'efs
senna est devenu une légende depuis ce
tragique 1er mai 94 and showed libère
caméra embarquée dans la benetton de
michael schumacher
juste devant lui ayrton senna à plus de
300 km heure le pilote de la williams
tire tout droit dans la courbe de
tamburello images terribles pour les
passionnés de formule 1 le choc frontal
ne lui laisse aucune chance
la voiture est pulvérisé ayrton senna
décédera ce dimanche 1er mai à l'hôpital
de bologne
cet accident mais fin week-end
cauchemardesque pour les organisateurs
le vendredi rubens barrichello sort
miraculeusement indemne d'une violente
sortie de piste le samedi début d'un
week-end noir l'autrichien roland
ratzenberger se tue senna prend la
nouvelle sur le lieu de l'accident et
décide de ne pas prendre part aux essais
j'avais de mauvaises sensations pour
conduire la voiture et l'a poussée vers
ses limites
je n'ai pas eu tour sur lequel je me
suis senti vraiment parfaitement à
l'aise avec tous ces accidents
je n'étais pas vraiment confiant
c'est la dernière interview d'ayrton
senna son compteur restera bloqué à 41
victoires et 65 pole position record
inégalé
issu de l'école du karting sénat
découvre la monoplace en 1981 quatre ans
plus tard il est en effet en volant
d'une médiocre thomas naert mais malgré
cela et après seulement deux courses il
réussit tout de même à marquer ses
premiers points
deuxième à monaco derrière cross
changement d'écurie la saison suivante
et première victoire en grand prix sous
la pluie condition qu'il affectionne à
estoril au portugal
c'est là sa force sur une lotus renault
6 victoires à monaco encore un record
trois titres de champion du monde tous
sur mclaren
personne n'a oublié surtout pas gerhardt
burger son ancien équipier et ami ce
matin un nouvel hommage à ayrton le
pilote autrichien est monté dans la
lotus renault du brésilien sous l'oeil
de la soeur du champion disparu pour
deux tours de circuit